submarines ancient temples and
rollercoasters
welcome to Cinecitta world inspired by
the studio of the same name that made
classics like la dolce vita and Ben Hur
the theme parks developers are hoping to
pull in one and a half million visitors
by 2015 and in turn reboot the Italian
movie industry cassia Ezra bhava Queen
Shinichi Dewar has been developed here
over 25 hectares with a 250 million
euros investment 1,000 and new hires
almost thoroughly among young people in
recent years the Italian film industry
has been more horror story than sizzling
romance from 2012 to 2013 money going
into productions dropped by over a
quarter the Italian government even
stepped in offering tax incentives for
filmmakers and cinecittà Studios has
suffered in its first six years it
turned out nearly 300 films in the last
six years it made just 50 the park's
owners are relying on these modern
roller coasters to bring life screaming
back into la dolce vita
struggling studios but will the legacy
of Italy's silver screen draw the
digital generation of today
Tom Gibson Bloomberg